and the reason democrats are forcing an
impeachment they know is going to fail
is that they want to distract you
an inconvenient fact they have
absolutely no idea how to govern now
look no further than their pathetic
track record
in a state like california governor
gavin newsom represented
that the future of the party was in
california is california dreaming all
the way
but what has he actually done california
completely
bungled the vaccine roll out
prioritizing illegal aliens
and prisoners over seniors businesses
and schools
still closed and violent crime is rising
in the state's biggest cities
unsurprisingly newsom's political future
is in dire straits
the effort to recall him is expected to
hit
2 million signatures by march 17th half
a million more
than they need to trigger an election
joining me now is one of the leading
republicans
california state senator melissa
melendez state senator good to see you
tonight
they're confident they have a shot at
winning this recall election
however could you just get another bad
democrat at the other end of this
well good to see you laura um you know
there's always the possibility of
getting another bad democrat in
california because
they're everywhere but uh the last time
a democrat decided to run in a recall
election to replace gray davis
that guy's political career was over
before he could even blink his eyes so i
don't think we're going to see that
again
um and gavin newsom better pay attention
because you know he seems to think that
it's just republicans who are upset with
his leadership it's not
i can tell you it is democrats it is
independents it is across
the board and he is not paying attention
he thinks just because someone has a d
behind their name that
you know they'll vote for him no matter
what i get news for him that is not the
case anymore because they are tired
of being locked up they're tired of
losing their businesses their kids being
stuck at home in front of a computer all
day long
teachers not teaching they're done and
he just doesn't realize that or he's not
accepting it
well he tried to spin his vaccine roll
out this way
no one is satisfied with the pace of
distribution
of these vaccines of course we have more
work to do
but we have made demonstrable progress
and we will continue to build on that
over the course the next days weeks and
months
days weeks months stay senator wrap it
up
okay look california has received about
7 million doses of the vaccine do you
know how many we've put into arms
about 4 million he's bungling it all
over the place he's fungaling it
senator melendez thank you so much for
joining us